A list has all the properties
of a collection.
So it has a group of things but
the objects have an order.
A shopping list, well not really
something programmers do with a lot,
happens to have a lot of the same
properties as the list we use.
There are things that might not
have the same type of object, but
they're still related to
everything else on the list.
The order doesn't mean much.
It's just the order that I ran out of
each item and there's no fixed length.
I could just keep adding things
to the end, or adding and
removing from the middle and
it doesn't really affect anything.
Again, what exactly
the implementation looks like for
adding elements will change based on the
language and the type of data structure.
We're still talking theoretically here.
So don't sweat the details too much yet.
In this lesson we'll explore
several types of lists.
Different programming languages
treat them differently.
Sometimes a list is incorporated as a
core feature of a programming language,
but what that looks
like can vary wildly.
The videos here will talk about the
theoretical concepts that could apply to
any language,
while the text will explain
the language-specific implementations.